both of the major parties and we're
talking about the United States here
hold their national convention during
the summer before the actual general
election so the Republicans will hold
their Republican National National
Convention and the Democrats will hold
their Democratic National Convention and
it's there that they officially choose
their candidates that will run against
each other in the general election in
the general election and a national
convention for one of the parties will
look something like this this is the
Democratic National Convention in 2008
you have all of the demo the delay gets
over here and everyone's all excited and
they start to cheerlead for their party
and for their candidate the Republican
National Convention looks very similar
and although there's a lot of energy
here there actually isn't a lot of
suspense going into the convention we
usually know already who the candidates
for each of the parties are going to be
and that's because each of the states
have their own selection process for
picking a candidate and as those
selection processes as we get the
results from we know how many delegates
they're going to send to the convention
and who they are going to or whom they
are going to vote for but there's two
ways that they can select those
candidates or those those delegates at
for the National Convention they could
either run a caucus they could run a
caucus caucus Oracle caucus let me spell
that right they could either run a
caucus or they could run a primary they
could have a primary and I'll start with
primary because that's a little bit more
intuitive it's kind of like just a
election that is based on party four who
do you for whom do you want to be your
nominee at coming out of the national
convention so for any given state
they'll have both a Democratic primary
and a Republican primary and on the
Democratic primary let's say candidate a
gets forty percent of the vote on that
on that election candidate B gets thirty
percent of the vote unless a candidate C
gets another thirty percent of the vote
what will happen is is that states
delegates on the Democratic side so
let's say that that state
just for convenience let's say that they
have 10 delegates 10 delegates on the
Democratic side that means that these
delegates will go on to the National
Convention and represent the different
candidates proportionally so out of
these 10 delegates 40% or 4 will
represent candidate a 3 will represent
candidate B and 3 will represent
candidate C when they go to the National
Convention on the Republican side it's a
little bit more nuanced you could have
similar results a gets 40% B gets 30%
and C gets let me do a different letter
so these aren't the same candidates so
let me let me do candidates D E and F so
you could have candidate D kind of did e
kind of did F and let's say let me just
do the percentage is slightly different
for fun so let's see if 45% over here
let's say you have 25% over here that
gets us analyst say you have candidate F
with 30% over here on the Republican
side it depends from state to state some
states will do it similar to the
Democrats where the delegates represent
the candidates in proportion to the
votes they have while some other states
have it winner-take-all and so for
example in a winner-take-all in a
winner-take-all state candidate D would
get all 10 delegates so the reason why
states do that is it's a stronger
incentive for candidate to show up to
that state if they feel like they're in
the running because if you think if they
throw enough money and marketing in that
state that's a big deal to take all of
the votes on the other hand if you're a
smaller candidate and you don't think
you can take it all it might be a
disincentive for you to actually even
show up at that state and you might want
to focus on the states where you can
actually get some delegates so that's
all a primary is it's really as kind of
you could view it as an election this
held separately on the Democratic side
separately on the Republican side and
those are used by the state's parties to
decide who which delegates go to the
national party and whom those delegates
are going to vote for a caucus the point
is the same thing to figure out who who
are your delegates that are going to go
to the National Convention and whom are
they going to vote for but the process
is a little bit different in a caucus
you essentially have people get together
in these events these caucuses in
different precincts and the most famous
of these are the Iowa caucuses so in
small precincts you'll have groups of
fifty to a hundred people get together
and they have and the different parties
have different ways of doing going about
it but they have a way they have
processes in place where people try to
kind of market for different candidates
they they campaign for different
candidates and sometimes they'll have a
cut-off that if one of the candidates
that one of the precincts don't get at
least 15 percent of the vote then though
the people who supported that candidate
then will have to give their their
support to another candidate so they
make sure that all of the delegates
represent at least a certain threshold
of voters but there's different
processes in place but the bottom line
is is once they at each of these
precincts they'll select delegates and
then those delegates will then go on to
the County conventions and then those
delegates at the County conventions now
these are representing more people will
then pick delegates to the district
conventions and then at the district
conventions they'll pick candidates on
to the state conventions and at the
state conventions they'll pick the final
candidates that go on to the national
convention now the two most famous
caucuses or primaries are the the Iowa
caucus which takes place in Iowa and you
have the New Hampshire primary you have
the New Hampshire primary which of
course takes place in New Hampshire and
they're important not because they pick
so many delegates that those delegates
are gonna tip the balance necessarily
these are both small states they don't
have that many delegates compared to
California or Texas or Florida but
what's important about both of them is
that they happen very very very early on
in the primary season and because they
happen early on in the primary season
the candidates that come off with the
lead here it's easier for them to raise
money because other people say oh I want
to give money my money to a winner you
know I don't want to give money in
candidate who's gonna just you know blow
it and and lose the money and lose and
lose the election regardless so it gives
you that it also is a big signal for
who's a front-runner because there tends
to be dynamic for whoever comes in in
wins or comes
maybe second place in the Iowa knew I
awoke aqus or New Hampshire primary that
those are the people that everyone
should pay attention to they get more
fundraising it's kind of a
self-fulfilling prophecy more people all
of a sudden take a more serious look at
them now the Iowa caucus just to be
clear the primaries all happen in on one
day and you get one you have the polling
results when people exit the polls and
then you also get the final results
pretty quickly this caucus process
actually takes over takes place over
many many months five months in the case
of the Iowa caucus and the results the
thing that the press focuses on is not
this final not this final result of who
are the actual delegates that go to the
National Convention the thing that the
press focuses on are the precinct the
precinct conventions where people get
together because coming out of those
precinct conventions the state parties
get the information on how many
candidates each delegate one going into
now the County conventions and this this
is the indicator that the press and the
media and everyone else likes to use to
see who's a front-runner in that
specific party's primary and the reason
why the Iowa caucus in particular gets
so much importance is because it is the
first caucus these results come out
before anything else the New Hampshire
primary this is the first time that you
have the direct voting for candidates so
you're getting I guess you're getting a
more direct number you're not having it
distorted or maybe cleaned up depending
on how you view it by all of the
different processes that might take
place within the precinct conventions